a gluten-free bread that I can stand yeah that's truth but it has cultured cane sugar cane sugar
salt and other things that don't sound good all the gluten-free breads seem to have the same stuff
throw it or keep looking um you know there isn't even any bread that's not gonna sugar in it so unless
you are making your own bread um you're not gonna you know I think it's a benefit having cane sugar
and cultured cane sugar versus having high fructose corn syrup that probably is in other
cheaper breads so I would say go ahead and use it you're just not like you're eating a loaf of bread
every day or maybe eating you know a couple pieces every couple days or something like that
as far as brands of gluten-free bread that I like I like canyon um I don't know if you could get
that where you're at um but canyon can't remember the name if that's the full name of it but that
is it I like that do you guys think that's a decent gluten-free bread